eux ce sont des gens qui se plaignent du
pouvoir se déplacer en tout cas dans des
conditions économiques possibles qui se
plaignent de l'excès de taxes donc
pourtant cette france qui travaille on a
l'impression qu'elle a marqué contre son
camp puisque la facture est douloureuse
ecoutez-la est représentée par bruno le
maire la ministre de l'économie il était
ce matin sur rtl je pense que les
événements actuels devraient nous faire
perdre 0,1 point de croissance d'autres
richesses nationales au dernier
trimestre et puis c'est la réalité des
commerçants c'est la réalité des
indépendants c'est l'arrêté
psychologique de tous ceux qui ont vu
leurs magasins samedi abîmé vandalisés
et pillés tagués tout ça est
extraordinairement violon à portsall mal
et c'est un paradoxe quand même c'est
vrai que c'est la france du travail
question posée
j'aime bien dit s'il vous plaît et je la
termine ce qui est un crime c'est la
france qui travaille qui mène fait
d'ailleurs ils manifestent samedi parce
que probablement que le reste de la
semaine est train de bosser mais ils
font du mal en même temps à ces petits
commerçants à ces artisans à ces petits
patrons dont parlait au nom d'allah
c'est peut-être là là là et dire les
limites des gels et jaune et de là où on
peut les soutenir sans limite c'est que
la solidarité s'arrête quand même à la
porte du voisin serbe là c'est vraiment
il ya même à l'intérieur des français
qui travaillent à une rupture ce
concrètement à deux semaines de noël
c'est à ce moment là que les commerçants
la restauration se fait le maximum de
chiffre d'affaires et les empêche de
vous je n'ai pas dit ça j'ai dit quand
même bien un individualisme exacerbé qui
existe aussi aujourd'hui qu'il faut
prendre en compte est le fait de
manifester
et mine de rien de manifester sur des
dans des zones où ils savent très bien
que les casseurs vont débarquer et vont
aller piller
ça oui mais ça aussi c'est une vraie bd
avec gilet jaune jusqu'en ya aussi ces
exemples cités moi même
les jeunes ont témoigné du juge de
classer en troisième mouvement oui ya
main mais je sais très bien
andré bercoff bruno le maire je voudrais
quand même il nous la baille belle le
cher bruno le maire quand même qu'il
donne encore des leçons alors qu'il est
qui recommandait dans son programme la
hausse la baisse de la csg
ap beau programme électoral de woods le
maire candidat la résidence ses intérêts
bien sûr on a le droit de changer
s'était alors pas là pour être ses rives
et poète sérieux je vous tiens une chose
on dit ce que vous dites mais je vous on
entend très bien je vous dis une chose
en faire une petit plus et je vous
assure que vrai pas votre temps quand
les français s'exprime pacifiquement
safin et la poubelle référendum sur le
traité de lisbonne poubelles 2005 2005
2013 les gens du voyage pour tous
demandent au conseil économique et
social
l'abrogation de la loi poubelles
consultation d'annoncés d'accord goubel
consultation tour d'amd là on aligne
deux dames c'est joseph m poubelle je ne
juge pas si c'est bon pas et tu as
généraux de la bioéthique poubelle quand
les façades s'exprime un peu plus vers
la manu ne soit pas oui mais non mais
non c'est pas ça de dénoncer notamment
pour être entendu mais quand le kenya
marcheurs 2000-2006 manifestation c'est
pure recul bonnet rouge en 2013 recul
2016 a dit selon antoine des landes
recul est aujourd'hui gilet jaune
on voit déjà le recul je ne roule pas la
violence si c'est ce que vous êtes en
train de faire
concrètement c'est vrai des anciens pas
de violence et de la défense des fois
c'est super c'est dans l'histoire de
france qu'il y a et il y a eu 1789
c'était sans violence non j'ai dit des
choses sympathiques quand même qu'ils
sont faits en fermant alors avoir trouvé
d'accord avec ce constat de toute façon
en gros si on n'est pas violent aussi on
si on n'est pas une main dans la rue on
n'est pas la seule chose que cette
énumération ou et montre c'est que la
démocratie fonctionne française
fonctionne très mal depuis des années et
alors effectivement de fêtes puis les
gens qui bloquent obtiennent plus
facilement lors
leurs enfants obtiennent satisfaction
pardon plus facilement que ceux qui
gèrent les jouets pourriez vous revenir
sur ce que disait pardon nous ne le
maire le seul point où je effectivement
ce que font les gilet jaune en bloquant
la sambre d'activité économique ça a des
conséquences dramatiques sur des piles
sur des bois de plus ou moins soit le
plus petit d'ailleurs bien les plus
grandes ailes ça fait un choc mais elles
pourront encaisser sur les plus petites
c'est un choc dramatique après je trouve
qu'il ya quand même une certaine ironie
ou j'ai un peu mal à l'aise en tout cas
avec bruno le maire qui dit qu'on va
perdre durant un point de croissance
tout ça pour 6 centimes sur la sur
l'essence d'un dernièrement il aurait
suffit aussi que le gouvernement
réagisse plus tôt et on n'en serait pas
là
c'est un grand jeu non c'est vrai dans
le lot d'abord d'abord remettre les
pendules à l'heure moi je travaillais
sur le dispositif de sécurité samedi
jusqu'à 13 14 heures il ya eu aucun
incident
c'est à dire la cazine 7 à 3 81 des
manifestants gilet jaune était là et
elle est pacifiste il n'y aurait aucun
incident là où ça s'est dégradé c'est
quand des casseurs notamment des groupes
venus de banlieue se sont pointés et
puis les des groupes de man qui sont qui
à mon avis s'intitule d'extrême gauche
ou d'extrême droite mais qui sont des
psychopathes en puissance et qui
viennent pour tout casser avec un
professionnalisme absolument incroyable
d'accord bon et c'est là où ça dégénère
donc d'un coup faut bien discerner deux
femmes est complètement quelle que soit
la manifestation que vous organisez
maintenant d'ailleurs on l'a vu au
moment de la loi travail ou les services
d'ordre de la cgt qui sont quand même
pas des perdreaux de l'année écrit
totalement dépassés mars et
professionnels de la de l'ultra violence
c'est ça qui pose véritablement un
problème premièrement deuxièmement bruno
le maire il va quand même un peu fort en
disant voilà les pauvres petits artisans
les pauvres indépendants les pauvres
commerçants de proximité
d'accord lui il est ministre de
l'économie qu'est ce qui fait au
quotidien pour faciliter le commerce de
proximité
les petites et moyennes entreprises qui
sont celles qui créent le maximum
d'emplois ça avait été dit au moment
des lois notamment celles sur cice bon
il ya quand même une ambiguïté de la
parole politique a rejeté sur le
mouvement leurs propres incertitudes et
leurs propres défauts si le ministre de
l'économie on n'a pas besoin de
l'entendre sur les conséquences mais
plus sur les causes on n'a plus besoin
de savoir et de se dire bruno le maire
qu'est ce qu'on fait pour s'en sortir
qu'est-ce qu'on fait notamment pour ce
culte de la dette qu'on est censé
rembourser et où on sait que quand on
rembourse quatre roues à la dette qui en
a trois qui partent sur les intérêts et
sur les assurances c'est peut-être ça le
vrai débat et redonner du pouvoir
d'achat aux françaises et aux français
juste un mot je voudrais redire ce que
disait à roanne à propos de
d'effectivement des décisions de manière
c'est sur les cinq centimes de hausse ne
faut pas oublier qu'ils ont aussi vendu
ça et ça c'est incroyable très mal en
disant ça va à l'écologie c'est la
pollution etc
on l'a vu le pourcentage est où on a vu
qu'ils allaient véritablement à la
transition énergétique
faut quand même pas raconter aussi des
histoires aux gens ça ne passe après
s'être un besoin de transparence de dire
l'argent payer les taxes où ils vont
exactement le publier le zerg a renoncé
et c'est là où nicolas non mais cette
avancée tout à fait raison c'est pour
nicolas hulot
quand il est parti et a fait son
discours de départ a dit on aurait dû
d'abord mettre les mesures sociales et à
après les mesures et surtout je vais m
en faire entendre des réactions les
internautes s'en passera avant je
voudrais quand même dire une chose et
c'est gratuit donc je le dis c'est que
il ya beaucoup de responsables syndicaux
de porte parole de l'association qu'on
voit plus souvent sur les plateaux que
sur le terrain patrick peloux on peut le
dire à chaque fois qu à une manif qui se
passe quelque chose vous faites votre
boulot d'urgentistes qui vous arrive et
après en disant voilà ce que j'ai vu
voilà ce qu'elle a vécu
donc respect c'est alors maintenant je
pense que serena d'internautes brownie
tôt nous dit les gilets jaunes c'est le
mouvement le plus hétéroclite les plus
hétéroclites qu'on ait jamais vu
il faut arrêter de dire que c'est
uniquement la france qui se lève tôt et
puis anti maquis fait cette analyse sur
laquelle gérard mey ont fait réagir
ce mouvement est néfaste à court terme
ça c'est sûr mais si la crise débouche
sur une baisse de la fiscalité
ce sera différent et renault on peut
penser ça que effectivement c'est
nuisible
à court terme et qu'il peut on peut en
espérer une amélioration plus grande
on peut oui si si ça débouche voilà moi
je joue honnêtement j'aimerais partager
cette analyse je suis plutôt je veux
dire avec plus de modestie xvi dans un
moment d'inquiétude je ne sais pas sur
quoi cela va déboucher
je suis inquiet de savoir d'abord de
savoir si le président de la république
ce soir faire des annonces qui sont
conséquentes et ensuite si ces annonces
vont suffire à calmer la colère de très
grandes défendre de dg les jeunes et
plus largement la cité française qui les
soutiennent assez large ea c'est assez
fortement
je suis inquiet de voir si ça va
s'arrêter je suis inquiet de savoir
comment est-ce que ensuite des mesures
vont pouvoir être mises en oeuvre
sociale ensuite il réforme ensuite
donc je ne sais pas si j'ai la
conviction que le système dans lequel on
est à bout de souffle donc de toute
manière il devra changer
la question c'est cette transition est
ce qu'on l'a fait dans le chaos nous de
manière démocratique
j'ai été spontané tous d'accord à cette
inquiétude vous la magie mais oui mais
totalement profondément et sur choses
nouvelles
sa couche tout ça touche toutes les
couches de la société c'est-à-dire aussi
bien les jeunes qui sortent et qui ne
savent pas quel emploi ils vont avoir
que les plus de 50 ans où les retraités
qui se demande comment va être pouvoir
d'achat nous sommes soit dit en passant
le pays d'europe avec le plus fort taux
de chômage des plus de 50 ans dont
combat on bat d'état de records et des
tas de paradoxes et c'est là où il ya
vraiment un truc moi qui me gêne
profondément c'est que je ne sais pas je
je en fait on ne connaît pas bac rond on
le connaît pas on était capable de
savoir l'empathie populaire que pouvait
avoir à jacques chirac ont ça on savait
comment finalement sarkozy allait réagir
ou hollande on savait parce qu'il y
avait une patte ise politique salariale
mais ce écologie y avait une patine paul
et là c'est vrai qu'on voit un banquier
on voit un gars ou vous allez au
comptoir de la banque vous dites que
vous avez un petit découvert le mec il
vous dit non il ya des indemnités il se
sera donné ce soir même après ces salles
et en sciences des salaires justes c'est
ça c'est quand même les français qui ont
aussi voulu se débarrasser de la classe
politique des services ils ont jamais
mis l'ambiance
ce procès n'a enlevé la parole libre de
la presse qui a révélé d'affaires fillon
et nous avions
monsieur le président maintenant
évidemment que la presse après six ans
qui a été parfait je vais là je veux
passer enfin la parade ensuite second
chez andré bercoff simplement je la
donne d'abord aux internautes
cette fois ci du figaro.fr puisque c'est
la question du jour redoutez-vous les
conséquences économiques du mouvement
des gilets jaunes et bien oui c'est une
majorité écrasante et ce n'est pas
surprenant
vous êtes 74% répondre positivement nos
jours et je voudrais revenir sur mac
rond parce qu'on dit vous dit patrick on
ne connaît pas macron le connais quand
même un peu et il a eu justement des tas
de choses très différents tous savaient
et ça jouer beaucoup sur le calcul
française n'y a pas de jugement saisies
à des cultures
qu'on soit d'accord ou pas ensuite il y
a eu quelque chose de très fort et en
fait c'est là où le bât a blessé même
s'il est inconscient face il n'est pas
dit comme ça c'est l'histoire avec
l'europe
quand aurélie attaché c'est pas ma con
qui dit nous sommes prêts à transférer
la souveraineté de la suisse ne va pas
alors partie du patron le nouveau patron
du parti la république en voilà et qui a
dit nous sommes absolument prêt il a dit
publiquement à transférer la
souveraineté de la france à l'europe
dans les cages assez hallucinant
deuxièmement ils ont montré il a
toujours montré que oui oui la france
très bien l'europe
or qu'est-ce qui s'est passé et que les
gens ont vu encore une fois de
l'interprétation
mais la donne on a bien vu que l'europe
de l'est a fait sécession d'une certaine
manière dont l'histoire de migration
copains par l'eau on a vu ce qui s'est
passé en italie
je constate simplement sans prendre
jugement moral que matteo salvini peut
circuler à la piazza del popolo à toutes
les villes italiennes
alors qu'on voit ce que macron fait
quand il va au puy-en-velay où il ne
peut plus sortir de la voiture sans se
faire insulter
je ne dis pas que l'un ou de l'autre je
dis simplement qu'on n'a pas tenu compte
de ce climat général sur l'europe et sur
la fin et que macro n'a pas donné un
récit national et avoir envie alors
qu'il a fait nous rappeler sur le bronze
il est allé dans l'itinérance mémorielle
qu'est ce qui l'a fait chuter un
mémorial a tout chamboulé fait insulter
un hebdo les un problème
mais yahia est bien vrai il ya un an
blair solution permet de le sujet
migration parler de sujets de
l'immigration analyse l'europe
andré bercoff ce matin à marrakech a été
signé le pacte